[Música]
faltava a todos é o meu nome já falava
em sou o bruno pinto responsável pela
marca brembo c's uma marca que neste
momento já está espalhada pela europa ea
europa e pela américa do sul é o tema
que eu acho que o que está aqui hoje
e porque muitas vans também tem algumas
dúvidas em relação ao papel é um papel
em branco e papel em branco porque eu
acredito que o papel em branco nós
conseguimos este ano e fazer tudo aquilo
que nós quisermos é é que no papel em
branco bisignani começa a desenhar os
seus primeiros traços a equipe com o
escritor começa a escrever nas suas
primeiras palavras
portanto ele fico muito e eu disse que o
meu papel
inicia sempre neste papel aqui este
papel num papel em branco
quero agradecer o convite que a
organização fez passar aqui sinceramente
é a minha vida é muito símbolos tal como
há muitos vocês com algumas
particularidades que moram mais outras e
outras que me orgulho metros por exemplo
e aqui vem um cacho de uvas com se
apanhava entre aspas a minha primeira
novela era teu quatro anos numa vítima e
caso os meus avós aos seis anos
consegui pegar fogo o quarto com os pais
aos 10 anos consegui partir um braço da
garota em aos 16 anos consegui partir
uma perna a fazer motocross traz claro
dizer que a minha carreira desportiva
acabou nesse momento
naquela altura é o meu pai só para fazer
uma função era sócia do vencedor de duas
das maiores empresas do norte do país um
setor automóvel para minha família tinha
que ser um exímio cantor tinha que pedir
alguma coisa mecânica e tinha que tirar
um curso porque aí é que eu tô a gente
dizia é que no final o melhor tubo é que
até setembro o emprego garantido o
melhor tudo é que ia mandar nos outros e
ao seu patrão
felizmente fui desmente e por valorizar
muito o que os outros dizem é eu sempre
fui muito tony bizarro
fui sempre muito porque o que estava a
fazer porque eu acreditava então quando
ele àquela altura quando fui para a
faculdade e muitos votos foram para
acuar a causa era a casa da praia viva o
casamento era pra avisa o carro era pra
vida
o apartamento da praia viva o emprego
era pra vila
quando eu saí da faculdade comecei a ver
que nada disso era pra viva
os prêmios para muitos nós o casamento
seja para a vida
pelo menos pra mim o curso não foi pra
vida é provável que existam até fui mal
no mesmo ponto porque minha família e
amigos que estavam economia ou o direito
porque era bom para as empresas se estão
mas foi muito para mim
encontrei o marketing no meio disto o
marketing como vai animar quem é que me
faço isso marco é quem faz a andar mais
um caminho eo aí o curso não foi para a
vida porque é fácil momento deixa a
digestão e torcer para o marketing é
causa e o carro não são ruins para a
vida os empregos não são para a vida o
casamento já vem depois 30 portanto já a
ventar mas eu espero que seja para a
vida
portanto antigamente aquilo que eu
acredito é que o que eu sair é que nós
chegamos aos 30 anos e parece que
fizemos o nosso papel já comportamento
escrito a garantia não é assim mesmo
hoje o nosso papel nós temos muito para
fazer
temos umas linhas para escrever portanto
terminou o curso e na altura que termina
o curso o pai nelson silva total da
empresa
o automóvel mas já não era administrador
das empresas torna sócia mas já não
tinha precisão o meu espaço não era
assim tão garantiu
não que importasse muito critério e
inteligência cria seria o fazer cria e
ser eu a terceira eu aprender e então é
aceitar um desafio internacional com
muitos dos nossos jovens e entrei numa
empresa gira o setor é muito engraçado
mas que nada tinha a ver comigo
na altura e entrei numa empresa
portuguesa chapa critical software uma
empresa conhecida e que não conhecia na
altura mais conhecida por trabalhar com
a nasa em portugal dirigida por um
senhor que chamavam saul quadros que era
na altura o empreendedor do ano em
portugal e que a lei no parlamento que
nada tinha a ver comigo foi o sport foi
dos automóveis faleiros martin e eu
peguei num novo tratamento que chamava
cinza espaço e aeronáutica por isso essa
imagem aqui não conseguia padre nasdaq o
brasil como muitos outros colegas que
foram outras partes do mundo quando eu
vou para o brasil é encontro o uso para
como a situação pra mim felix a ofensa
pessoal ou profissional que a empresa
naquela altura no brasil não tinha
instalações não eu não tinha colegas
trabalho e projovem 25 ou 26 anos
obrigou uma proporção muito maior porque
o atual permite nos entrar em contato
direto com a estamo empresa tinha
contato direto com o silva empresa o
confiança aprender e crescer e
desenvolver é é uma das minhas as minhas
capacidades e que o prêmio do brasil pra
onde já ter aprendido antes de ampliar
como a uma situação nunca mais como vai
aqui o que minha família
eu e os meus amigos diziam pra onde está
mas nunca achei que o meu papel foi
escrito pelos outros para que os outros
diziam ah vai ser um emprego a vai ser
mas se programava a mandar nos outros
ok não eu até quero isto mas quero ter
isto por mérito próprio
é no brasil tenho algumas presas muitas
delas positivas outras rosa entanto uma
das presenças também no brasil e uma
reação com encontros brasileiro era
quando eu ligo no brasil
bruno pinto então a gente ia no meu nome
e eu voltei mais porque agora a
confiança com uma outra pessoa não vai
mas porque é que o sr bruno pinto é que
não é sobrenome pinto aqui tem outra
história
a primeira ação hoje em portugal movemos
campeões visita movem ou no meu nono e
mel
já imaginaram o que significa o meu nome
no brasil portanto falar que alguns
pintos qual faziam ao treino
desculpa
depois disso outras duas prensas cultivo
quando caí com o quadro foi dois ou três
dias antes de vir para o brasil afirma
chamá la de uma chamada da empresa caiu
por causa de dezembro no infelizmente
com sal ao seu alcance ou não vai poder
viajar para o brasil
disseram para mim eram permissão para
praga onde desmarcado na agenda
tirar umas férias eu tirei três férias
jogo que procedia ao rio de janeiro para
levar as minhas férias no primeiro via
na manhã em portugal em dezembro
estamos no aeroporto bruno vamos seguir
para o brasil daqui a oito horas temos
de buscar eu gostar
caraá gina e tive que ir buscar a sua
aeroporto espaço muito curto
é eu naquela altura pensava como é que
como é que é possível uma pessoa depois
passar uma situação tão difícil ainda
consegue nem consegue ter força e
consegue fazer o que o faz tão mãe
consegue gerir consegue empreender ea
poesia regiões das 8 às 23h começando
pelo caminho e eu cada vez mais ficavam
ficava confuso com isso
no final o que se percebe que quando nós
fazemos realmente aquilo que nós estamos
é é não saber o melhor antídoto para nós
enfrentarmos todos os lucros da nossa
vida todas as barreiras da nossa vida e
foi consentida com com aquela pessoa e
mais uma aprendizagem mais uma coisa que
eu acho que todos nós vamos escrever no
nosso papel para allen não deixarmos que
os outros escrevam por nós é que vai ser
o nosso papel tamanho e devemos escrever
nosso papel é que o que nós gostamos de
fazer o que estamos a escrever é e
aquilo que para o qual nós precisamos
voltar mos e trabalhamos quando voltei
para portugal
não vim trabalhar o setor automóvel viu
trabalhava para pagar tributos para a
empresa onde estou hoje e na altura 2011
havia aqui um forte sentimento de
consternação nosso país que ainda hoje
nota
mas na altura vivia mais um carinho que
era toda a gente andava desconfiado
atoladinha estava cabisbaixa é toda a
agenda viviam um momento péssimo mesmo
os nossos dias do ponto de vista
empresarial até excluir um banho e
chegavam à noite ficamos a noite falamos
com os amigos falamos com a família e
éramos apanhados todos numa onda de
pessimismo e nós e nós começamos a
pensar em sumaré e adicionar o porquê as
pessoas dizerem tão mal no nosso país e
isso será que nós já fizemos o
suficiente pelo nosso país já fizemos a
nossa parte só tirar nós assumimos a
nossa responsabilidade
e então nós entre conversas na na
empresa
pensávamos como é que nós poderíamos
usar a nossa empresa a ultrapassar esta
essa situação difícil mas ao mesmo tempo
pensar mais alto
vamos ganhar na fotografia é a
fotografia melhor forma
nós mostrarmos o que quer que seja é
melhor forma de mostrarmos paisagens e
objetos mas a minha melhor forma nos
mostrar os sentimentos é melhor forma
nós estamos mortas e nós percebemos que
o futuro fica realmente a melhor forma
não somos portugal e então nós fizemos
um desafio um desafio um desafio às
pessoas que se identificavam com o que
nós sentimos nós queremos ser parte da
solução não queremos ser parte do
problema
nós sentimos que não temos feito o
suficiente pelos outros temos feito
sucinta o nosso país
ok então vamos lançar um projecto
projeto chamado portugal ao destino
portanto o objetivo era pressionar
porque o pneu se no mundo elas possam ir
lavar promoção de portugal com certeza
que não era nossa mas nós acreditávamos
que podíamos dar mais chuva e então
saímos saímos da nossa caixa same da
nossa zona de conforto a quem somos a
fotografia próximos da fotografia
começamos com um papel em branco porque
estamos a desenhar o projeto
completamente sozinhos e desafiar cada
um dos portugueses que não estavam
sequer normalmente não eram chamados
habitualmente para a promoção do atual
limite nos mandassem as grafias e
fotografias que os policiais conhecem de
todas as regiões
não estamos aqui a falar só do algarve
ou só do porto salvo jogou todas as
regiões do país siti fantásticos que e
aos que gostam e que vão monitorar via
alguém lá fora que se identificou que o
resposta das pessoas foi foi inequívoca
nós nós vamos uma plataforma online nem
dois meses conseguimos meninos 107 mil e
53 freguesias do nosso país uma marca
que um caminho difícil e que acreditamos
que a maior parte dos empregados turismo
e não tem essa base do fotografia e mais
não eram as fotografias daquelas pessoas
normalmente tirava uma fotografia com o
seu país era de que não vão se
escavarmos as pessoas a cama da sua
região que é uma das pessoas que sentiam
que não tinham feitos então o país e
queremos condicionar o o hotel como não
se no mundo queremos fazer outra coisa
quisemos mostrar consciência das coisas
em grande e que portugal consegue ser o
número um como as pessoas junto com a
sua se inspiram começou esse motivo é e
quisemos criar o tal maior álbum
fotográfico do mundo
o álbum tem oito metros comprimento 4 e
meio de altura por barragem naquela
página cirurgião país no final nós
conseguimos record do guiness não temos
que andar com o álbum eo preço por fora
a mostrar quer acidentes quer a turistas
mais uma vez chamamos as pessoas a
participar tivemos entre os voluntários
que mais uma vez sentiu o mesmo que nós
criamos dar alguma forma o país assim
uma situação menos favorável mostrar a
cultura do nosso país e mostrar as
paisagens fantásticas
nós já temos uma região praiana outro
lado temos a montanha mostrar a
gastronomia fantástica que nós temos os
tops orientações nós vivemos nós somos
um país computador por meio mundo
conseguimos conquistar meio mundo as
suas quando vão lá para fora os
portugueses normalmente são valorizados
fazem um estudo trabalho e que nós
tínhamos era mostrar isso mostrar isso
vamos mostrar isso ao mundo
fizemos mais depois que temos criado em
estudo
tivemos a visita da chanceler angela
merkel
na altura am foi estava muito ligado à
instabilidade na europa muito java
as entradas ou troika nosso país
pelo menos é assim que quero é visto é o
é quando vai a portugal e as pessoas
estavam à espera estavam a preparar pra
senhora da paz pela como manifestações
nós fizemos em frente não nós não vamos
ficar com manifestações nos vamos fechar
não vamos mostrar isso a chave para o
marca portugal não é só o emprego não só
quantas não é só o défice em portugal é
muito mais que isso ok vamos nunca baixo
leva uma garrafa de vinho deve
desmanchar issa leves de um queijo e no
meio disto tudo é o nosso alvo
não preciso pessoal ea social e assim
acabava se a acaba por cento em todos os
canais ç ã o intervenção bento temos
essa opção o primeiro-ministro e acabou
rebaixado amanhã
nós não sabemos se os que comentaram o
vinho ou se jogou ou senhor aquino
chouriça mas nós queremos dar um sinal e
sinal mas caixa falha no sinal ao país
nós temos que nos orgulhar da que
fazemos outra e essa nota que os que
observar e espero deixar no papel nosso
papel em branco escreveu escreva sempre
que eu acredito é que o pelo qual sou
apaixonado e esse é um projeto
essencialmente paixão é um projeto de
decoração e foi por isso que nós
conseguimos trazer tanta junto conosco
tanta gente à nossa volta nosso no
início não somos sozinhos como dissemos
e 800 milhões com entidades com pessoas
a entrar não só os feridos
apoiado na nós vamos pra frente e como
as pessoas vêem boas intenções e vem e
as coisas podem ter um impacto não só
para nós mas só para os outros
as pessoas acabam por nos ajudar
acabamos por thomas ser compensados pelo
ter um trabalho que nós temos
termino e concluindo quero dizer a todos
e quero deixar uma última mensagem quero
fazer uma pergunta quantas as pessoas
aqui aqui dentro estão satisfeitas com a
vossa vida pessoal e profissional nem
tava frio e extra os que não estão
satisfeitas com a vida pessoal ou
profissional muito pouquinho confiança a
todos vocês só quero deixar uma mensagem
que não tenham receio sempre que
precisarem de vir em uma folha branca eu
próprio estou a acompanhar folha de
papel em branco o papel em branco é o
manual ou proteína água para nós
sonhamos eu vou cuidar por nós prevíamos
a maior propriedade por nós tínhamos é
uma nova final para nós vivemos
obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]
[Música]